[Musique]
d'enseignement
altermag et lavrov et depuis près de 20
ans la voix de la russie dans le monde
pense lénine ni programme jusqu'à
récemment l'indéboulonnable ministre
russe des affaires étrangères semble
avoir endossé d'autres élus ceux de chef
de la propagande qui répète sans état
d'âme les éléments de langage qui sut du
kremlin sur la guerre en ukraine
une transformation totale aux yeux de
lawrence cannon ancien ministre canadien
des affaires étrangères qui l'a bien
connu j'aime pas dire ça mais il a
malgré ses pulls note il peut avec
lequel on était en mesure de pouvoir
dialoguer je pense qu'il est avec le
temps de vivre est véritablement
terminée
[Musique]
diplomate de carrière sergueï lavrov
était auparavant apprécié de ses pairs
habile négociateur
ils défendent est toujours avec force
les intérêts de la russie mais ses
interlocuteurs voyait en lui quelqu'un
avec qui on pouvait discuter
s'entendre et même rigolé
aujourd'hui ça guèye lavrov est
considéré comme un apparatchik du régime
de moscou un faux comptes visés par les
sanctions internationales
le domaine du sport m'a dit aussitôt
pour cela et côté par les diplomates
occidentaux lorsqu'il prend la parole à
l'onu il était hors de question
d'écouter le narratif qu'il déploie en
ce moment est de lui laisser une tribune
comme si c'était normal
dans un temps normal
difficile en effet pour eux de prendre
au sérieux les théories du complot
défendue par le chef de la diplomatie
russe lorsqu'il prétend par exemple que
les états unis financent des
laboratoires pour fabriquer des armes
biologiques en ukraine pourtant
lorsqu'il affirme que les massacres de
marioupol le déboute ya sont en fait les
mises en scène que les victimes sur des
comédiens randy winn et d'hommes
[Musique]
politiques
africains appa pauvre d'eau nous aurons
un civiliste 4e
minute racisme
je pense qu'il ne pourra pas
nécessairement ce qu'il dit c'est un
homme trop intelligent pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir croire ccc pro bowl à la réalité
selon les observateurs c'est que même
s'ils restent de très fidèle à vladimir
poutine sergueï lavrov n'a aucune
influence sur lui ce soit selon cet
analyste était de partir ou de rester
de cannabis warrior
est fixé tous t il uniquement
adaptés et quitter le gouvernement de
vladimir poutine s'est aussi renoncé à
beaucoup davantage
sur ses rachats et s'en fait
date
[Musique]
selon une enquête du militant
anticorruption alexeï navalni
aujourd'hui emprisonné sergueï lavrov
profite beaucoup de son poste doré sa
maîtresse et sa belle fille sans emploi
officiel procéderait pourtant des
voitures de luxe et des appartements
valant des millions
[Musique]
il est aussi question de vacances à bord
de yack de prestige et de voyages
personnels en jet privé appartenant à
des oligarques du multimilliardaire
ne se gagnent ou à les garder au chaud
et on y met de la nano je vais te
promènes rockstar qu il est a minima
une situation promettant qu'ils
rendraient vulnérables et donc aussi
un acte en date
le destin de sa gay lavrov reste donc
intimement lié à celui de vladimir
poutine qui ne semble vraiment pas prêt
de partir et même si les ponts avec le
gouvernement russe paraisse difficile à
rétablir lorsque cette crise finira par
finir c'est gai lavrov restera sans
doute pour l'accident le moins mauvais
des interlocuteurs